When I began, it was just meant to be the world's greatest undershirt...
...just for football players.
And quickly I found out it worked for baseball players and lacrosse players.
And it just grew from there.
And it didn't begin as one massive vision...
...but it began with being committed to one idea...
...and making it the very best that I could.
For brands, you know trust is something that is built...
...in drops and is lost in buckets.
And every drop that's taking place from every day, from every sale,...
...from every shirt, you know, has been establishing that trust.
And when we make mistakes and we certainly do.
We compromise and we take away that trust.
When we do, we lose it in buckets and we're hyperaware of that.
And so building trust and building equity...
...and pouring that in every single day is incredibly important.